rund 2300 Kilometer bis zur US-Grenze
Raphael würde am liebsten gleich
durchfahren das mühsame leben hier
hinter sich lassen
[Musik]
wie etwa die Hälfte der Menschen in
Guatemala lebt der 32-Jährige von der
Landwirtschaft immer öfter sorgen
Wetterextreme für dürren oder
Überflutungen die Bauern wissen nicht
mehr wovon sie leben sollen
schauen Sie sich das mickrige Ding an
normalerweise müssten die Kolben viel
größer sein
zurzeit reicht die Maisernte gerade mal
aus um den Eigenbedarf seiner Familie zu
decken ein Hurrikan hat hier alles
zerstört der Schaden ist nachhaltig
[Musik]
kommt
das ist der Grund warum hier nichts mehr
gut gedeiht
der Hurrikan hat eine dicke Sandschicht
über die Felder gespielt
wie Raphael sehen Millionen Menschen in
Guatemala keine Perspektive mehr
Klimawandel dazu Korruption und Gewalt
einer Studie zufolge wandert jeder
sechste guatemal Theke in die USA aus
für Sozialarbeiter wie Markus liegt der
Schlüssel bei den Jugendlichen sein
Herzensprojekt jungen
menschenmöglichkeiten aufzeigen wie sie
im eigenen Land erfolgreich sein können
der 42-Jährige leitet das Centro kederte
übersetzt das bleibt hier Zentrum in
verschiedenen Klassen lernen Jugendliche
Fähigkeiten die Ihnen dabei helfen
sollen einen Job hier in ihrer Heimat zu
finden
sehr gut am Ende quando wenn der
Nachwuchs besser ausgebildet wird werden
die Jugendlichen auch einen Job in ihrer
Gemeinschaft finden oder ein eigenes
Unternehmen aufbauen können und dadurch
können sie all ihre Talente ihr
Potenzial ihre Fähigkeiten nutzen um
ihre Gemeinde ja unser Land zu stärken
für viele Jugendliche ist es unmöglich
regelmäßig zu einer Ausbildungsstätte zu
kommen schlechte Infrastruktur lange
Wege also hat Mark Forster für gesorgt
dass die Lehrer auch selbst in die
Gemeinden gehen um auszubilden wie in
diesen Handwerksbetrieb Immanuel hat
hier seine Ausbildung zum Schweizer
gemacht und wurde am Ende sogar
übernommen
in den USA ein besseres Leben führen
kann
[Musik]
wenn deine Familie deine Freunde deine
Heimat hier sind
[Musik]
das Centro kederte läuft so gut dass die
Idee nun auch in andere Gemeinden
getragen wird unterstützung kommt von
den Regierungen Guatemalas und der USA
es ist eines von zahlreichen Projekten
die guatematiken stärker an ihrer Heimat
binden sollen und es funktioniert
trotz solcher Initiativen suchen immer
mehr Menschen einen Ausweg oder
versinken in der Kriminalität wie hier
in milanoeva die Kleinstadt gilt als
gefährlichster Ort des Landes Gangs
regieren wer stört stirbt wie dieser
25-Jährige hingerichtet auf offener
Straße und natürlich auch hier wie im
ganzen Land Korruption auf allen Ebenen
wer sich dagegen wehrt muss um sein
Leben fürchten wie hohan zanoval er war
bis Juli 2021 Guatemalas Anti
korruptionsbeauftragter der 40-Jährige
kam krummen Geschäften des Präsidenten
auf die Schliche wurde gefeuert lebt
jetzt in Washington im Exil
mächtigen ziehen ihren Nutzen aus einer
unterernährten Bevölkerung einer
Bevölkerung die kaum überleben kann das
ist eine Quelle billiger Arbeitskräfte
die Leute verstehen das korrupt des
handeln die Umstände dafür schafft dass
es ihnen unmöglich ist ihren eigenen
Lebensbedarf zu decken
öffentliche Schulen unterrichten nur
vier Stunden am Tag auch deshalb
engagiert sich die Hilfsorganisation
glaswing international hier die
Mitarbeiter wissen dass die Jugendlichen
täglich Gewalt erleben Sie versuchen
ihnen Hoffnung zu geben und vermitteln
dass es Alternativen zur Flucht gibt
heute sollen sie aufmalen was Sie zum
einen mit ihrer Heimat verbinden und was
sie sich von einer Flucht in die USA
erhoffen
was wir mit Guatemala verbinden ist
Gewalt Gefahr Hunger Gangs davor haben
wir Angst deshalb wollen so viele in die
USA sie hoffen dort auf ein gutes
Einkommen Bildung ein schönes Zuhause
und dass sie Geld zu ihren Familien hier
schicken können
Ziel der Organisation ist es eine
Alternative zu den pandias den
Jugendbanden zu bieten Werte wie Bildung
Selbstbewusstsein und Gewaltfreiheit
stehen dabei ganz oben
ich bin davon überzeugt dass es unsere
Anstrengungen wert sind schauen Sie sich
die lachenden Gesichter an und die
Träume die sie haben die
Meinungsvielfalt hier und das an einem
Ort an dem ich jedes Mal wenn ich das
Haus verlasse nicht weiß ob ich Lebens
wieder zurückkomme
auch wenn wir verschiedene Sprachen
sprechen sind wir doch alle gleich wir
sind Menschen vielen von uns fehlt es an
Möglichkeiten alles was wir wollen ist
eine Chance
zurück bei Raphael er genießt seinen
Feierabend zu Hause bei seiner Frau und
den fünf Töchtern nur seine älteste
Tochter fehlt sie hat das mit Hilfe
eines Schleppers in die USA geschafft
ein minderjähriges Kind mit ungewisser
Zukunft tausende Kilometer weit weg für
viele Familien in Guatemala völlige
Normalität
als meine Tochter sich auf den Weg
machte war ich traurig denn ich wäre
selbst auch gerne gegangen aber das
konnten wir uns einfach nicht leisten
vielleicht kommt ja auch irgendwann mal
meine Schatz
Raphael und seine Familie hoffen dass
die Tochter eines Tages in den USA
arbeiten darf und ihnen Geld schicken
kann bis dahin wird er wie Millionen
seiner Landsleute versuchen seine
Familie irgendwie über Wasser zu halten